- If you are in this area of the room,
what would you like a, a rap about?
- [Audience Member] Genghis Khan.
- Genghis Khan.
(audience cheering)
- Yeah, oh, popular.
And you said that so cool,
you didn't even like,
you didn't even change your face,
you just went, "Genghis Khan."
(audience laughing)
Yeah.
It's weird, innit?
Because, like, usually you
shout out the name of a rapist
and people don't cheer.
(audience laughing)
But.
No, come on, right?
It's just that in the past, right?
It feels like, if you're
like, "Oh, he raped,"
that's a bad thing, but if you're like,
"He raped and pillaged,"
you're like, "That sounds
exciting, doesn't it?"
(audience laughing)
"The Vikings raped and
pillaged across Europe."
"Wooh, pillaging. That atones for it."
Okay, Genghis Khan.
No, because, like, it's like,
what like 20% of the world's
population has half his DNA
because he put it around a bit.
(audience laughing)
Right? Genghis Khan. Amazing.
Let's come to, um, this area of the room.
Let's get our next
suggestion from you guys.
What do you want a rap about?
- [Audience Member] Feudalism.
- Feudalism? Is that,
is that what you said?
- [Audience Member] Yeah.
(audience laughing)
- Cool, okay?
You, how, what percentage of this room
do you think understand what that is?
(audience laughing)
No, I'm just saying that,
it's going to be real boring
for that whole portion of the room.
(crowd laughs)
Obviously, I know what
it is because, Oxford.
(audience laughing)
Middle of the room, what
would you like a rap about?
- [Audience Member] Vasectomy.
- Vasectomy. Is that
a suggestion for this?
(audience laughing)
Okay, vasectomy, great.
Um, vasectomy, feudalism,
and Genghis Khan.
- [Audience Member] Genghis Khan.
- Yeah, no, I know!
(crowd laughs)
Let's come over to the corner over there,
what do you guys want a rap about?
(audience laughing)
- [Audience Member] Bungee jumping.
- Bungee jumping, have you,
have you done one or more?
- [Audience Member] Yeah.
- Oh, how many?
- [Audience Member] Just one.
- Just one, and one was enough.
(audience laughing)
- Did you do it on your
own or with a friend
who is sadly no longer here?
(audience laughing)
Where, where did you do it from?
- [Audience Member] New Zealand.
- New Zealand, yeah,
that's weird, isn't it?
'Cause you go the
opposite way, up and then
(audience laughing)
You're all children! Shut up.
The dumbest joke ever.
And people here, what
would you like a rap about?
- [Audience Member] Russia.
- Russia, okay, let's, let's
kind of, zoom in on that.
Be more specific.
What about, what about Russia?
- [Audience Member] Putin.
- Well what about Putin?
- [Audience Member] Riding a horse.
- [Audience Member] His hairstyle.
- Riding a horse and his hairstyle.
You call going thin on
top a hairstyle? Is that?
(audience laughing)
- [Audience Member] Not in Russia.
- What was that?
- [Audience Member] I said not in Russia.
- Not in Russia. Okay, I guess, yes.
Okay I was gonna quote Yakov Smirnoff but,
(audience laughing)
I'll steal the joke, innit?
Okay, so, Putin, riding a
horse and his hairstyle.
Bungee jumping in New
Zealand, Genghis Khan.
Don't worry,
(crowd exclaiming)
Okay? Feudalism, and.
What, why do you think I've forgotten it!
What's wrong, you're
looking at this and going.
(indistinct murmur)
(audience member laughing)
Oh, okay, cool.
Do you only call your children
by the order they were born in?
(audience laughing)
This then, lovely people, it's
gonna to be a freestyle rap.
As I said, that's a
rap made up on the spot
based entirely on your suggestions.
It's, uh, it's going
to be pretty exciting.
You seem very skeptical.
Including my man who said
Genghis Khan, but don't worry.
Just a little bit.
(rap music playing)
That's all I want.
Um, and yeah don't worry,
it's not going to be
anywhere near as atrociously,
embarrassingly, toe-curlingly
bad that you're expecting
a privately educated, middle class,
white, British boy to be.
So, uh,
(crowd cheering)
I'm going in right now.
♪ You got the hop but we got the hip ♪
♪ I wanna cut off the little
tentacles with a snip ♪
♪ Moving all the tubes, maybe get a clip ♪
♪ Put it down there now
doctor say that it's ♪
♪ Difficult, you can't reverse it ♪
♪ I'd be wanking after
it, 'cause I've heard it ♪
♪ You gotta make sure,
the tentacles are empty ♪
♪ You used to have sperm
in there, like plenty ♪
♪ It used to produce nearly every day ♪
♪ But now it's empty, dusty and gray ♪
♪ It's just one seminal
vesicle in the sack, like ♪
♪ I remember in the day,
when, all the way back ♪
♪ I would put out lots of sperm ♪
♪ There were so many, yeah,
I was waiting my turn ♪
♪ They were swimming for the
egg, they were going to be ♪
♪ Making up the fetus with the ovary ♪
♪ And then it's gone,
probably, under the knife ♪
♪ With the suggestion of your lady wife ♪
(audience laughing)
♪ Like, come on, I
don't wanna get filled ♪
♪ With a baby, and I'm not on the pill ♪
♪ I don't want IUD, contraceptive ♪
♪ So off to the doctor, yeah check it ♪
♪ You're like, have ya got a
license and a medical degree ♪
♪ Or is it just in the back alley ♪
♪ With a hobo, with a cleaver ♪
♪ He's like, please stand
still, don't leave sir ♪
♪ (audience laughing) ♪
♪ He was chopping over there ♪
♪ And your hands, head bopping ♪
♪ You were like, yeah we know
that he forgot something ♪
♪ But I didn't. Shut up.
Breakout like a prison ♪
♪ Let me see this, like feudalism ♪
♪ I'm a serf, right at the
bottom of the pyramid ♪
♪ Farming in the field to feed
my wife and my little kids ♪
♪ Then I get up, to the lord above ♪
♪ You got the knights, and
I wanna give them a shove ♪
♪ And then you put this in
the great Earth context ♪
♪ It's a system that
keeps boots on the neck ♪
♪ Of the people in the
UK in medieval times ♪
(audience cheering)
♪ They were picking over sieves,
there where peas in mine ♪
♪ They were trying to find,
and give it up to the King ♪
♪ And he would serve the
Baron, when they were asking ♪
♪ They would muster the knights,
they would get an army ♪
♪ See I told you, you
guys wouldn't go balmy ♪
(crowd cheering)
♪ Now, you're no adoring ♪
♪ Medieval history is totally boring ♪
♪ Well let me take it back yeah ♪
♪ this will do a charm ♪
♪ I'm a guy coming over
like Genghis Khan ♪
(audience cheering)
♪ Hands in the air with
my boy on the side ♪
♪ Coming to a village, he be like ♪
♪ "Aye." I won't do the accent ♪
♪ I don't even know what it sounds like ♪
♪ Genghis Khan, where does he go ♪
♪ GK coming there on his
horse, and then it fell over ♪
♪ And of course, he used
to own a large area ♪
♪ A big empire of the land, but sadly ♪
♪ On his horse, expired ♪
♪ He got bucked off, and
I think you'll like this ♪
♪ Didn't it explode like Appendicitis ♪
♪ And it killed him ♪
♪ Well, some people theorize ♪
♪ If you wanna get down low from up high ♪
♪ The quickest way to
return to something ♪
♪ Is going down on a cord bungee jumping ♪
(crowd cheering)
♪ And when you're goin down
got your blood rate pumping ♪
♪ You smell a weird little
whiff of something ♪
♪ You're like, well,
it's so fun to do this ♪
♪ But as I'm going up and
down Earth, I do shit ♪
♪ In my own pants, where do I go ♪
♪ Yeah I'm here, um, runny hell now ♪
♪ I'm looking up on
the bridge at the guy ♪
♪ Who did it before me ♪
♪ In Russia, he's real big ♪
♪ He be looking down like ♪
♪ Ah, I'm assuming you don't know me ♪
(audience cheering)
♪ I am Vladimir Putin. I'm up
here, I like to wrestle bears ♪
♪ I get out my pecs, I've got no hair ♪
♪ Thin on top, but people say ♪
♪ I'm the handsomest
man in Leningrad today ♪
(audience member laughing)
♪ Leningrad, whoa. We
gotta rename it, sir ♪
♪ That'll be out in Moscow
and St. Petersburg ♪
♪ Where am I? Of course,
on the back of a horse ♪
(audience laughing)
♪ Only ride this'll be
a nice filly of course ♪
♪ I be up here feeling no shame ♪
♪ I cause dissenters' pain in the Gulags ♪
and the mane on the
horse is longer than me,
but I give him a nice sugar
lump and I leave Communism.
(crowd cheers loudly)